before I can set up a business I've got
to teach my Brigade to cook
but running a kitchen in a prison means
getting my head around a whole new level
of security so I've got my bell or keys
can I get rid of this [ __ ] whistle
sorry I mean I mean so you have to keep
hold of the whistle oh the prisoners
have to use knives to become chefs and
the governor has agreed to let them have
their own sets but under strict
conditions at the end of the session he
must like aim for these tools in the
hands of someone who intends to do some
damage to another person that is one
lethal weapon to protect me as well as
the prisoners access to the knives will
be strictly controlled at all times and
this has to stay locked to retirement
yeah thank you worryingly for me the one
thing I haven't got is the key to the
exit let's get the measure yeah thank
you
I'm starting to feel like the prisoners
aren't the only ones who are banged up
morning morning you guys you well yeah
the last time this lot worked together
it almost fell apart right guys that's
all please so I want to make a few
things clear my kitchen my rules every
time you walk through those doors I
understand we're coming here to what
we cannot start pissing around joking
around when we piss around and the jobs
not getting done you're gonna hear me
guys right this is where I'm up against
it here these things if one of those
goes missing this place and gets shut
down in minutes and if somebody does
that to me to the team I'm going to be
so pissed off okay
right all of you get into pairs and find
a section if this lot are going to graph
the long side me they need to know how
to cook but even making a simple soup
and baking bread is an uphill struggle
one knee up wayworn to one bitter spoon
yeah
so looking for two years those two
spoons it's fun you can do it now I mean
we've got this opportunity and we can do
it I'm hopefully actually those change
my life in it that we all get to put
application I come out and get a job
that kind of stick
softly
[Music]
even still a home mr. wises it should
hopefully just be about ten minutes okay
yeah that came to learn but everything's
rigid in health and we get taken away
when they're called upon Paul why is a
recovering heroin addict a staggering
six to two percent of prisoners start
their sentences as drug users Paul can't
get through the day without a dose of
methadone heroin when I was about 16 17
gonna start taking the correct I was 23
that's when things got really out of
control and you don't start taking drugs
thinking I'm gonna be a junkie and I
mean you think we can control it at 16
Paul wanted to be a chef but only lasted
a few months like catering College
biggest mistake of my life taking drugs